how's it go bro my guess welcome back to
jazzpunk this gaming is exactly what you
think it is which makes no sense which I
guess is the best way to explain it if
you know what I'm saying we started a
new mission mission numbered thus we're
now in Chinatown was supposed to follow
the K boy we came from here and we're
going to fail of the key boy fan of the
key boy hmm oh yeah I want to go see
some Chinese strip club a disco disco
disco bomb I said disco don't mom okay
what they could say wait do I speak
Japanese now okay hi try this but that
oh I love those it's like a rodent shed
all right nom nom nom okay okay now I'm
starting to think you just [ __ ] with
me I throw it in his face
freshly-squeezed pigeon you know what
Yolo a monkey what I love monkey what
what kind of Chef are you I don't know
you you don't know if I click on okay
I'm some the hell is happening here
don't break the fourth wall okay y'all
God what the [ __ ] okay oh yes the
[ __ ] but yourself at a mana
[Music]
Aries happening okay
your vote our advice okay that is
[ __ ] creepy man
what okay
you mean the flies have been what what
what really come back here where is he
Varis die die
blood dude got you now you dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
fly for dinner don't make me slap you
you're not that kind of girl that brings
in what the stop by the racing side of
them
why do you store brains inside a place
quiet deep voice you do I'll slap
everyone Oh
[Music]
they're all blank
oh god ah ah ah oh you're no look at me
[Music]
like that why not you again
yes I am have you seen me like in this
360 okay I'll eat your whatever this is
it's pretty good don't tell me it's like
big dicks I'm not sure I want to go in
there but okay Jenny my sinuses okay
I don't think I have shoes okay all
right you're welcome
this is mine now I'm an influencer
please I may not enter well that's okay
I'm here for the Sochi and the [ __ ]
oh that's the guy named well I lost me
is insurgency to party
how do you know well I don't know why
the Queen's mean I think it's the best
what this Oh little GU how's the
fold-over actually let me keep my shoes
on hi guys bet Jets here you got to keep
his choice but I don't got to okay dumb
you can tell me why go goddamn it stop
liking it all right well we need a plan
that's [ __ ] yeah don't oh god oh god
oh god is it dead
is it dead oh god oh god I don't want to
think about it I'm sorry I'm sorry
why don't you just lock the door
Oh God go away there's a Scott thing
what am i doing
okay we hit the spider and then we take
it with the can that's supposed to go
like five of them two three five four -
wait the last one girl oh yeah it's on
the one of the plates
hey fire
[Music]
now what do I do
Oh No hey see that did you see that [ __ ]
oh my god
no way I'll get them off you I'll get
them off you're fine you're fine you're
fine oh my god don't worry just stay
still at least of all this yes I got
almost got them to stay still that is
[ __ ] disgusting
open wide well what are you gonna do
what do I do with this now alright let's
do it on its food Oh
[Music]
oh now he has diarrhea nice this is what
we do what b-but he goes to the ladies
bathroom what I like it's kinky stupid
stupid stupid stupid this is what you
get for for being a cowboy target a
quiet all right
I got this I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with this
this is this kiddin it is his kid name
you know what you've been great
call me sometime baby return to the
daleks asian girl great turn to the
station what you gonna do it work what
you gonna do I'm from excuse me I don't
think you know who you're talking to
here exactly I am the flower Mak that
fly my thing
no no no no shame on you
Oh Chet oh oh okay hi hey boy boy
alright slap your ass yeah that's right
BAM play 360 don't tell me what to do
[Laughter]
we've tried to reason with you you know
how you hear that bowling ball weirdest
right baby please don't hurt me
we'll see about that [ __ ] this game is
so [ __ ] weird man hey goddamnit no
one loves me what are we doing here
alright what does it say
light the inside all right that feels
good
from everybody yeah what no I just
probably like most lighting to the part
that last job seems to attracted us a
bit more heat than usual yeah that's
very kind enough it'll wait for things
to cool down a bit I'm ok with that
in the meantime I like posting ah I love
occasion all Spencer's paid fit two
cards that results oh god oh god it just
turned into a hentai again alright
friends got a friends episode here hope
you guys enjoyed watching I sure as hell
enjoy playing maybe like if you did is
always I really appreciate both your
brother to cool
stop stop no you're not yo my you nice
or whatever then god it's just like I'm
sitting here just look that's kidding
you look beautiful no I can't whatever
[Music]